Hello, my name is Mike Denny.
And welcome to This Week in
Android Development on Monday,
January 27, 2014.
Last week, Nazmul and his
special guest Laura Klein
discussed the
differences between
qualitative and quantitative
measurement on UXD.
Todd continued his
onslaught of learning.
Neto Marin lectured us
on design in Portuguese,
and Tony Chan spoke to us in
both Mandarin and in Cantonese
on what's new in
Android 4.4 KitKat.
This week, Todd
continues to take us
to school on achievement enums.
Joe Fernandez makes his
debut on DevBytes showing us
how to record app
videos directly
on our Android devices using
only USB cable and adb.
And finally, there are
two special episodes
being released later this week.
The first is a
PlayByte from Todd,
and the second is a
DevByte from Paul Carr.
Make sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
so you don't miss them.
That's all for This Week
in Android Development.
I'm Mike Denny.
Until next time, just
hold on, we're going home.